all right we've got more sponsored
memberships to give away here you'll
remember that two weeks ago a user who
goes only by the name gr sponsored six
free memberships for people who could
come up with clever incoherent rants in
the style of this particular user last
week we gave away for membership
sponsored by Jennifer karein and the
theme there was patriotic progressivism
or I guess really progressive patriotism
either one better way to say it either
way either way is fine with me
I now have a viewer Marshall brats who
is getting in on the action and I think
this is a good option if you don't feel
like having to do anything for your
membership if you don't want to have to
write an incoherent rant or a
progressive patriotic letter this is a
slightly different setup that it that I
think you're going to like Marshall is
sponsoring half of 30 memberships okay
he's a huge fan of the sports and
politics TV series known as 30 for 30
so he's sponsoring $30 towards 30
memberships right he is paying half of
30 memberships you pay the other half
and these are going to be first-come
first-served if you want a half-price
membership Marshall brats has already
pre paid for half of 30 memberships if
you want to pay for the other half and
you can lock in that half-price rate for
as long as you want email me through the
contact form at david pakman.com the
subject make it whatever free membership
Marshalls memberships membership get
Conda with whatever right and say I want
one of those half-price memberships and
the first 30 people to email me will be
sent to coupon code and that will be
that and just so everybody knows Pat now
has several hundred thousand memberships
he is not allowed to participate in this
thing I was going to resell them on the
black market oh this is a listen you've
got enough stuff going on with the
Keurig okay so last thing we need is you
of reselling memberships on the black
market
Pat is not allowed to participate so 30
non current members it's for new members
that's the one stipulation
email me Marshall brats has paid for
half of your membership you pay for the
other half
david pakman.com click on contact us
these go quickly these can go quite
quickly I like this because there's a
number of way to allocate goods and
services you don't do it by merit or by
seniority or by need or might be this is
first-come first-serve this is
first-come first-served absolutely so I
will update you tomorrow as to whether
there are any of those remaining but
let's do it get in touch with me get one
of those half-price memberships